es un nuevo día en el puerto de amberes
uno de los funcionarios que pide no ser
identificado analiza el último
cargamento que acaba de llegar
debe verificar que no hay trazos de
droga este embarcadero belga es
considerado la puerta principal de
entrada de cocaína Europa solo en 2022
se incautaron 110 toneladas
[Música]
un contenedor puede ser seleccionado por
sospechas de narcotráfico por ello
siempre abrimos este tipo de cargamentos
y buscamos entre todos los paquetes o
bien entre aquellos que el escáner haya
identificado como sospechosos
[Música]
con 240 millones de toneladas de
mercancías al año y con 160 kilómetros
cuadrados de extensión el puerto de
amberes es uno de los que maneja mayor
volumen de tráfico en Europa
Easy portavoz de aduanas advierte que
los cargamentos provenientes de América
Latina sobre todo los que contienen
fruta son los que más preocupan
queremos aumentar el control de
contenedores que provienen de América
Latina
por eso Hay nuevas inversiones que
anunció el gobierno belga de 70 millones
de euros y con el compromiso de
contratar a 118 aduaneros
la lucha por combatir el contrabando de
estupefacientes se ha convertido en
motivo de preocupación la comisaria
europea interior el vallohanson
recientemente firmó un acuerdo de
cooperación entre Bélgica y Ecuador para
controlar Los buques que salen a Europa
el tráfico de cocaína en la Unión
Europea está aumentando y se estima que
tiene un beneficio de 10 mil millones de
euros este dinero va directamente a las
organizaciones criminales
al gobierno de Bélgica le preocupa que
el país se convierta en un narco estado
por ello ya ha señalado que no
escatimará recursos para dejar el puerto
de amberes libre del narcotráfico